RK CY ANTHIS IS HE
FIVE
>>EILL DO EVETHING
GETHN RTNERSHI IN SODARI TO SPO
TESF TH HUMANARIA AND I
SECUTY NDS O UKRNE A
E UAINIAN PELE
>>udgeir: VE PRIDEN
KALA HARRI OUT IN LAND
INGER BT T CLE U THE
FIGHR JS OVER RAINE.
EAN BEN AINISATION
CLAING AREAKWNN
MMUNATION A THE REAN FO
WOULHAVEOTN UKRNIANS THE
AI DEFSE CAPABITYO FHT
F T RUSSINVION.
HAIS CLAINTHE U. IS
QUESTIONBOUT. I A I T
>>HA KD OFLTERTIVE PLA
GET MATERLS TO HP UKRNE
DEFE ITLF, ESPIALLY N
AT YOU HE DLINED LAND
OFR ON JETS
>> I WT TBE VY CLR.
ENITESTATND POLARE
UNIT ANDHATE HA DONND
AR PPARED T DO TO HP
RAINNDHE PPLEF
RAIN
Jud Pir:ND T VIC
APPANTLY ALLOROW.  IS
ACCORDG TOPOLICO WHI
HOUSEFFICIALSAYARSS
NOTHEREO ME DEA B
MELYS AYMBO OTHE
ADMINIRATI'S CMIENTOUKINE.
WH HARRISD, WEVER, W
INWKWAOMEN LEIS.
>>ANTETONOW IF Y THI
AND IOU A THENITED STES
SCIFILLY --
>> O
AUGHR]
>> ARID IN NES A FEND
[LAUTER]
Judge Pro:JESSE, IL G
TO YO
>> Jesse WE, HUNR WAS SY.
>> Jud Pir:UNTER?
>> Jse:YES.
SOY.
GELDO.
I N'T KNOWHETH SHEIDT
QUESON BECSE S WAS JT P OROULDTE
KEDILL YOUUYS ACCT
FUGE.
SHE AAYSCCEPTS REGEES
REFUES A SHE CLDN'ANDLE
IT A S TOSSE ITO THE
LISHPRESENT.
THAT W STRGE T THEN CACE
AN LAU DURING TIM OF
PUTISOT TBE LKING AT
IS A SAYGO HIELF, TSDOOTOOK LIK
ONTHEN U HAVE A AMAUR
HO -- BIDEN SDENT JET, THE
BIDEAYS IT S TOLHD IT,
ESIDT'S ID.
CNTED RASE
LIVI, S WENOW WHE SEONE
S NO IA WHHEY E
LKINABT.
>>OURE THE EXPE.
>> Jse: SHESA, TOHE
EXTE, ITERMS OF,N LIG
OF,NRTICAR,ST RELATES
TO
THE IS G O SIAL MEA -E SA KALA
KEHE'S TRYINTOIT T
WO COU FOR AERUN
AT'S HOWHE SOUN.
M SICK OFHEM SAYG NHING
ESCIAL TOTOPAYINGHAT
HE W'T .
NOWEOE HAV SAIHAT
BUT WHY N KEE PUTESSI?
WH NOT MBE Y, YOU KNOW
WH W MIG ACTLLY- WE'
NOAKINGNYTHG O THE
TH RSIAN BOER, MBE TOWOVE
SOUBSNTO THE BCK A,
VISIT IN SWITZEAND.EN TO
KNKNHE DO, MBEELIV
A BQUETF ROSEAYBEHE
A WTES A LTLEOMETHINGN
E NOTEGENIS AD.
BECAE RIG NOW PUT- T
EKSOURROD THE CAPAL-
ZENSKYS IN DEE TUBLE IF
STAR HIM OUTND SD I
ASSAINS.
>>ud Pir: GEN THEACT
ACCEEFUGSHEN SHE'S ICHGE OTHEOR
ALLY - IT'STUNNINGSH HAS THE IN
HORSOWER OF FOUHGRAD.
Y I SERE?
DN'T SHE KNOW S'D BE ASK
THER O A MSION THAT WA NT
DESTED T FAI AND THIS
HAPPED AGAIN A AGA TO HE
Jud Pir: INTEIONAY?
I TNK THEDMINTRATN -SHWAS GOI T
BECAE S W GOI TOELIV
WHENHEETS THER AER THE
THER TO SHO SYMLIC E
LATIONSH.
R PEORMAE WAS VY MU
HA A DELIVERLE T SAY THE AR GOI
DELIVERAE, S DIDN'TNOWHE
THE ARET GOIN O ABOUT W
AT'SHEOST PORTANT THI
E COD HA DONE TAY I
OVID CLIT
EVERYONEAYIN HEL US OF
UNRSND. JALINSRE O T SEND
MIGSRENOT.TH MIG B GD DESION.
BUT CA YOUXPLA I TO US?
EY A NOTBLEOO THAT.
EHOUL NOTAVEAKEN THE
ASSIGNNT IHE WASTOINGTOEBLE T D,
OR SHEHOULHAVESAID I HE
GO AN IDE WHY DON'T W
REFUESRE LCOM THEY HA
>> Jge Pro:LL GHT.
AHD, GRE
>> Gg: WTE SETHING DO.
I PROBLY C'TAY AT. >>udgeirroHE-
SHE CLD BECEERNSITE.
I'LL A YOU IS, GERAO.
ARE U ADY?
E CA GETERYXCITED ABO
ICE AIKEN THE TO T KK --
FAIROINT:HINK TT'S
>>udge Pir: ALOF AUDN
ANDHE INTERTION STAGE.
CRITICIS BECSEHEEEMED
POIN ANDUNRE, TO NA'S
KINDF CISIVENE. IT ANY
ETHEOR N S HAD
LIVEBLE,HEOULDAVE EN
RUSSN TK COLUM WIT THEIR DAY OF
VELIN MSILE AANK AFTER
NKR WIDRON, BLONG U
RUSSN TA.
GETTGTHIS, ZELSKY ISOING
A GAT JOB,E SHODELEBRATE
THEI COURE. AITTL ST
AITTLPTIMISM ITEADF
THAT OFFE.  NVOUSAUGHR
FIGURE TT -- - I WTOLO HE I WT I
>>udgeirro: S'S T. >>eral: B SHG
TO- YAN - Y CAN
ILL ASPIND MYEADLE --
EADLE IS TT THE
RAINNS AIN'TEAT YETND
WE'REELPI THEFIGHTND PUN I THII
SN'TUC GOO IDEA>>udgeirroS TH WA
TH WRE NOTN IT TO W ITS
BUT SHE LOU FHISJOB.
R LAU ISUNTTLIECAUSE
EASN' LAUING AT AOBOUSHING THA
COD SEE.
WASN INSIDEOKE ORTS.
SOT' KINOF LEHAT E TH DOI THERE?
I DOT UNRSTA IT
E'SIKE CHIL
SHE' ON B IP. SHS LE A CLD ALLE
E THCOCKT, BLEASE
DON'T UCHHE BUONS.
SHE'S N ALLOW THAMPACT
ON ANYINGECAU TY DON'T
TRUS HE
SHES RHT N AOLIS JOKE.
I LE THAT S SD FULL OP
AT'SHEUNSERIOU STUF
WE DOOTEE THIORT O ITYI TH IS M
BLEM IS WHAHE WAS RERRE
, S'S AMBLE OFUR
COERN.
ND AHOCKGUDACIOUS
PLOMIC EORTND W ND IT
SWIFY.
SPEN A L OF TIME, BILONS O
WE'V G TO SD OUR BT THE, NHE JEA
NTSU. WEEED OBAMUMP, SH.
TWO, T COMNATI -- W ND
DIATNN STEROS TTEXESSE HOWUC T
DISGUSD B THIND HOW IENT
AREN SPPIN T BLOOHE
D POTENAL WOR W 3.
THISOLON THE SUFRING A
MAKE USOOK KEE D'T
CARE
Dan CANDDNE OTH
THG?
E H AESSAGE TENDO THE
ERIC PEOPLE
WE HEN'TALKE ABOUT THE
UKRAIANESPONSEND TIR RETIONOER
ABMAL.
THEMPOKEITHPTIMM FO
NGING O ERYOR THE
FEELIK YOUERE CFORT.  NOT
Jud Pirro:HE H FAID
ALL O THE.
YOU ARE ASKG HOW Y CAN HELP
U CAN JNOX IN SPORTG
DONA NOW BY GOI TO ORTS
DCROSS.O/FOX
OV $2 LLN H BEENRAIS.CONG ,ORRIO